[Musique]
peaufiné au studio pour m'éterniser ce
qui sera un gros but en direct de paname
un peu comme ça danger les martyriser va
dire ça me passionne j'écris souvent eh
ouais je rappelle que pedro côté nama
fantino de l'état tu mets moussoro
céréales ya pointe son nez raconte ma
vie les petits trucs qui sont autour de
moi le truc que je remarque qu'en
général le rap français avec une
évolution incroyable et fait partie de
nos vies à tous maintenant parce que du
rap y en a pour tous les goûts
ah ouais moi ma star scène le rappeur
préféré avec booba rohff la mafia k 1
fry moi j'écoute du rap j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup écouté
ntm michel aussi en solo iam king james
beaucoup plus l'ancienne génération que
la nouvelle je veux pas mentir
moi je suis pas trop rap moi je suis
ouais donc c'est à dire je tournais la
série je découvrais un monde un peu je
suis plutôt rail tu vois je suis
sentimentale il s'agit mais ça va pas je
mets un peu cheap khaled ça sera le
directeur c'est bercy 2008 non c'est un
morceau de ntm et ses annexes de kool
shen qui dit on nous censure parce que
notre culture est trop basanée
représentent pas assez la france du
passé
donc on rappait dans les mjc ça allait
mais aujourd'hui le phénomène a grandi
dieu merci et puniques sa merci on passe
pas dans leur radio l'essentiel c'était
de sortir de la cave et les gens le
savent mais les gars y'a pas ce qu'ils
organisent un concert gratuit au moment
où j'écoutais du a effectivement on
rappe et ça les mecs rappelle le fait
que qu'on n'était pas invitée dans les
émissions de télé que ça passait pas en
radio maintenant maître gims remplis de
sable de france sotra nous remplit de
stade vélodrome d'un coup le rap est
devenue la première musique de france et
moi j'ai complètement assister à cette
mutation là donc je me sens un peu
militant et validé c'est celle à la
continuité logique de l'évolution du rap
en france c'est pour ça que valider ne
peut pas être une série comme les autres
je crois qu'elle jamais personne qu un
peu un truc pareil tf1 première fois la
seule complexité était de se dire
comment on fait pour le personnage de
apache et pour le personnage de ma star
puisque tous les deux sont des rappeurs
comment on fait pour que ça ressemble
pas forcément ce qu'ils font eux comme
style da et ça a été mais première mes
premières discussions avec moussa qui
joue ma star et avec les banques qui
jouent à page c'est légal pour pas que
ça ressemble à ce que vous faites vous
holloway
l'europe de ma star tu veux c'est ça
rappe qui a su s'adapter au fil des
années parce qu'on semble que voilà il
est pile et il n'est pas jeune comme un
clément ou comme un carnage et on sent
que c'est genre d'artiste qui justement
comme on dit dans le milieu a vécu l'âge
d'or mais qui a su s'adapter et qui est
assez polyvalent qui sait faire tous
types de sons il a l'oreille musicale
pour faire les sons qui puisse plaire
justement au public et apache c'est ça
ap lma pas charmant type et c'est leur
carte au trésor
est ce qu'une différence entre un ticket
à passe dans le rap oui oui forcément
parce que prison pour mineurs je
n'aurais pas écrit vous que c'est une
histoire d'apache est pas le score
d'atik sud ont le bac pour la drogue je
me pointe à pitre et après clairement
dans la fusée ça peut être un titre que
je regardais pour mon projet
106 n'a pas ce que racontent les textes
d'apache c'est principalement c'est sa
vie en fait de manière générale et c'est
à la fois sa vie de manière plus
sensible et touchante comme sûr présents
pour mineurs tout comme ça peut être
plus un truc de d'attitude de temps je
suis là quoi je suis charismatique et je
vais le montrer en fait c'est ça c'est
vraiment l'exercice d'ego tripes
[Musique]
et trois jaunes pour le regard clément
la scène qu'on va tourner aujourd'hui
c'est la scène où j'arrive j'allais dans
un studio de fou malade avec mon rapport
préférés et je vis un rêve rire
aujourd'hui d'avoir des plongera ap tous
savaient vraiment bien je pense ok
j'arrête en q1 comme un braqueur que ben
beau hasard - s'il doit donner une
définition du rapt apache girex un rap
tient moderne mais empreint de tout un
bagage culturel rap classique plus je
school nous permet d'être à la fois
pertinent pour les anciens mais d'avoir
l'énergie et la fraîcheur des les gens
de son âge est ce que tu veux que je
fasse un truc de beauf faire un truc de
mec est là même si je vais rentrer pour
un morceau qui est très très sensible
touchant et tout ça reste la bagarre la
recherche de la performance boxer avant
une prise comme comme on peut le voir
sur le making-of
en fait pour moi c'est juste un moyen de
relâcher la pression et c'est un
sentiment de de lâcher prise en fait
quand on sait de la respiration aussi et
puis avant de monter sur scène c'est
aussi mon rituel donc ce soit avant le
actions ou avant le
je vais vous d'un cancer s'est pas tu
t'emballes il ajouté une création
originale à découvrir en avant-première
en ce moment sur my canal